salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
bonne année à toutes et à tous j'espère
que vous avez passé un bon réveillon ici
on a fait une de ces fêtes du coup il y
en a qui un peu la gueule de bois bon de
mon côté ça va j'ai encore les idées
claires enfin j'espère pour vous
expliquer d'où vient cette fameuse
gueule de bois qui nous tombe dessus les
lendemains de soirée un peu trop arrosée
et comment on peut y remédier ça je veux
bien que tu m'expliques
cheers c'est de l'eau pas de problème
non c'est par là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh là là
le chantier c'est ici qu'on a fait la
fête bon je vous rassure on était
nombreux et on a consommé avec
modération enfin presque tout le monde
tout juste un peu pompette
heureusement il a dormi à la maison
d'ailleurs il a dû se réveiller avec une
de ses gueules de bois cela dit pas la
peine de faire des excès moi-même ce
matin je ne suis pas complètement dans
mon assiette en fait 4 verres de vin
peuvent suffire à donner la gueule de
bois parfois moins c'est variable en
fonction des individus selon le sexe la
masse corporelle ou bien les habitudes
de consommation celui ou celle qui
consomment plus régulièrement sans faire
d'excès bien sûr et moins exposé que
celui ou celle qui ne boit que très
rarement
ouf l'expression gueule de bois dattrait
du 18e siècle à l'époque avoir la gueule
de bois signifiait avoir la gueule
c'est-à-dire la bouche sèche comme du
bois ce qui arrive souvent après une
nuit de fête elle a ensuite évolué pour
décrire l'ensemble des symptômes que
l'on associe à une surconsommation
d'alcool certains parlent d'intoxication
alcoolique les médecins eux préfèrent
parler de vésalgie le mot vient d'une
norvégien Joyce qui veut dire réconfort
et le grec algia qui signifie douleur je
me demande comment est fait pour
souvenir un truc comme ça un jour pareil
moi aussi la gueule de bois peut se
manifester de différentes manières
fatigue maux de tête douleur au niveau
des yeux vous voyez ce que je veux dire
cette sensation désagréable quand on
tourne les yeux sur le côté
[Musique]
sauf
d'autres ont la gorge sèche tremble et
on a même qu'on est trop de mémoire on y
reviendra un peu plus tard les premiers
signes apparaissent en moyenne 8 à 16
heures après la consommation d'alcool à
ce moment là on est dans le pâté comme
on dit c'est en général au bout de 24
heures que la sensation de mal-être
atteint son paroxysme curieusement au
moment où le taux d'alcoolémie est déjà
retombé à zéro et la petite caméra aussi
était là hier soir maintenant nous
allons essayer de comprendre ce qu'il
nous arrive lorsque nous sommes victimes
de la gueule de bois et pour cela je
vous propose d'aller faire un tour à
l'intérieur de notre organisme direction
le foie
quand on absorbe de l'alcool le foie est
notre meilleur allié il est capable de
métaboliser
transformer si vous préférez
95% de l'alcool que nous ingérons le
reste est éliminé par la sueur l'urine
ou l'air que nous expirons mais ce
travail lui demande un gros effort si
notre consommation est trop importante
et trop rapide le foie ne peut plus
assurer sa fonction il se trouve en
sur-activation la machine ne fonctionne
plus correctement l'éthanol contenu dans
le foie et dégradé sous forme
d'acétaldéhyde il s'agit d'un composé
chimique qui provoque une intoxication à
des concentration trop importante
l'acétaldéhyde agit comme un poison il
est responsable d'une partie des
symptômes que l'on ressent quand on a la
gueule de bois les nausées
l'attachycardie et même des rougeurs sur
le visage
ouf ce côté là rien à signaler
mais avant d'être métabolisé par le foie
l'alcool passe préalablement par
l'estomac et c'est de là ne font pas bon
ménage
à petite dose un verre de vin comme
celui-ci bon
ne pose aucun problème à notre estomac
mais une consommation excessive peut
entraîner la libération d'acide
gastrique qui vont irriter la muqueuse
de cet organe alors ce n'est pas très
grave mais dans certains cas ça peut
aller jusqu'à l'inflammation de la
muqueuse gastrique c'est ce qu'on
appelle la gastrite alcoolique elle est
aussi responsable des nausées que l'on
ressent les lendemains de fête de
ballonnement de contractions
douloureuses qui peuvent aller jusqu'au
vomissements là il faut faire attention
parce que la guerre est alcoolique peut
durer même une fois la gueule de bois
terminée dans ce cas il vaut mieux
consulter un médecin alors vous l'avez
sûrement remarqué depuis le début de la
vidéo il y en a un qui n'arrête pas de
boire de l'eau normal il est déshydraté
déshydraté moi avec tout ce que j'ai bu
je sais c'est un peu contre-intuitif
pour comprendre il faut regarder du côté
du cerveau
en temps normal celui-ci sécrète une
hormone
antidurétique appelée
vasopressine son rôle est d'envoyer des
signaux au rein afin qu'ils retiennent
l'eau en quantité suffisante pour leur
bon fonctionnement mais il se trouve que
l'alcool bloque la libération de cette
hormone du coup l'organisme utilise
l'eau à volonté pour éliminer l'alcool
résultat on fait pipi plus souvent et on
se déshydrate ce phénomène explique
aussi pourquoi les gens qui ont la
gueule de bois ont souvent la bouche
pâteuse la bouche sèche vous souvenez
vous sèche gueule de bois la
déshydratation est également à l'origine
de tout un tas d'autres désagréments
comme les maux de tête la fatigue mais
aussi l'altération de la mémoire il
n'est pas rare que certains souvenirs de
la veille s'effacent tout simplement
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de mes lunettes
tu les as sur ton nez ah ouais
dans les cas extrêmes certaines
personnes connaissent même de véritables
blackout ils sont incapables de se
souvenir de ce qu'ils ont fait la veille
et parfois de l'endroit où il se
trouvait alors évidemment la question
que tout le monde se pose c'est
existe-t-il un moyen pour éviter la
gueule de bois un lendemain de fête
j'aimerais tellement vous dire oui
malheureusement il n'y a pas de remède
miracle bon j'ai quand même quelques
petits conseils à vous donner pour
limiter les dégâts d'abord consommer
avec modération éviter de consommer le
ventre vide ensuite consommer lentement
n'enchaînez pas les boissons alcoolisées
des pauses agrémentées de plusieurs
verres d'eau lors du traditionnel repas
de famille du 1er janvier d'éviter le
saumon fumé et le foie gras ce sont des
matières grasses qui obligeraient votre
foi à faire des heures supplémentaires
idem pour le café tous les aliments
acides comme le jus d'orange ou le
chocolat évitez-les là encore pour
préserver votre foi optez plutôt pour
des pommes ou des bananes des laitages
allégé en matière grasse ou des
protéines maigres comme la viande
blanche et pour lutter contre la
déshydratation rien de tel que de l'eau
et un bon bouillon de légumes bien chaud
en plus de vous réhydrater il va
faciliter la digestion allez un dernier
petit conseil pour la route ne prenez
surtout pas le volant si vous avez la
gueule de bois même si votre taux
d'alcoolémie est retombé à zéro votre
corps ne sait pas remis de la soirée de
la veille particulièrement votre cerveau
des chercheurs de l'Université de basse
Royaume-Uni ont démontré que la
concentration les réflexes et la
coordination des mouvements restez
altérée pendant la gueule de bois alors
prudence merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout j'espère que ces
quelques conseils vous seront utiles
pour vos prochaines soirées et pour ne
rien rater de cette belle année 2023 qui
commence n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
encore une fois chers épicurieuse et
épicurieux je vous souhaite une très
bonne année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]